des bandelettes de plastique implantées
dans le corps des femmes pour traiter
l'incontinence
jamais j'aurais du far so une chirurgie
mineure qui peut avoir des conséquences
majeures moi dans mon collaborateur dans
mon bassin c'est sensible c'est
douloureux
ce dispositif médical ne pose pas de
problème pour la majorité des femmes
mais pour certaines c'était la
catastrophe semble que quelqu'un doit
admettre l'ampleur du désastre mais ce
qu'est la baisse des charges de mon
combat c'est de trouver quelqu'un qui va
m'enlever cette bande d'être là parce
que 500 à saint dié pire
cynthia gagner est une super sportive le
sport a toujours fait partie de sa vie
mais aujourd'hui il est devenu synonyme
de souffrance
wassa 15 force comme cela sans fameux
commence à tirer en 2015 à l'âge de 38
ans cynthia été opéré pour un problème
d'incontinence urinaire
depuis des douleurs au point jeunes sa
vie j'ai mal vraiment dans les n 1 go du
bassin des hanches comme des 100
d'argent en fait je me sens comme une
femme de 70 ans comme des milliers de
canadiennes chaque année cynthia s'est
fait implanter une bandelette de
plastique sous l'urètre on lui a dit que
ce dispositif médical faisait des
miracles sans lui dire qu'il pouvait
aussi faire des ravages
mon combo c'est de trouver quelqu'un qui
va m'enlever cette bandelette l'eau
parce que parce que je veux excuser
parce que ça soit ça sans pied pays
cynthia doit aujourd'hui se battre pour
retrouver sa qualité de vie parce qu'on
lui en ai planté un dispositif médical
créé pour faciliter le travail des
médecins et non la vie des patients
[Musique]
motocross randonnée pédestre demi
marathon canotage vélo de montagne vélo
de route
cynthia gagné n'était pas facile à
arrêter
ce soit que ma qualité de vie moi
c'était beaucoup de bouger l'exercice
physique intense peut fragiliser le
périnée
comme beaucoup de grands sportive après
son premier accouchement
cynthia gani s'est mise à souffrir
d'incontinence urinaire à l'effort
courts et pulls me retrouver tout
embrouiller
c'est très désagréable cynthia fait des
exercices de renforcement du plancher
pelvien
mais ça ne règle pas le problème elle se
retrouve dans le bureau du neurologue
peut-être que j'aurais pu persévérer ça
ce sont les bandelettes sous urétral
synthétique
elles sont implantées par voie vaginale
pour soutenir l'urètre elles ont
graduellement remplacés les chirurgies
plus invasives ou les bandelettes
étaient faites de tissus humains on en
un plant près de 11000 par année au
canada chez la majorité des femmes elles
ne créent pas de problème mais pour
cynthia ça a été la catastrophe
je me souviens avoir des bonnes douleur
bambo de faim j'ai de la difficulté à ma
sortie de ma voiture
c'est vers une douleur 1 face à l'eire
le dossier médical de cynthia révèle une
trentaine de rendez-vous médicaux au
cours des deux dernières années on m'a
dit que ça pouvait être la ménopause qui
me posait ses douleurs l'eau mais par
contre les tests sanguins desk plupart
n'oppose personne ne pense à la
bandelette pas même cynthia jusqu'à ce
que la situation se dégrade davantage
je me suis mis à avoir des douleurs ou
votre vagin à l'intérieur difficultés à
aller aux toilettes à uriner aller à la
selle
les activités quotidiennes sont pénibles
les relations sexuelles douloureuses et
par dessus le marché
l'incontinence est de retour à l'été de
mes dix huit cimetières voit pour la
première fois l'urologue julie
morissette qui lui a posé sa bandelette
deux ans et demi plus tôt celle ci
propose d'enlever une partie de la
bandelette qui semble trop tendue
à ce moment là j'ai dit non j'aimerais
mieux investi des plus loin pour savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment
l'urologue note dans le dossier
la patiente désir des certitudes les
certitudes ne tarde pas à venir
je sens un corps étranger c'est ces jeux
là son endroit en novembre 2018
l'émission française cash investigations
présente un reportage sur les treillis
vaginaux qui est responsable du calvaire
de natascha comment un implant qui doit
soigner
peut-il détruire une vie les treillis
dénoncé dans les missions sont
différents de la bandelette de cynthia
ils sont plus imposants et soutiennent
la vessie plutôt que l'urètre seulement
malgré cela
cynthia reconnaît ses douleurs et son
histoire à travers celle des françaises
j'ai eu l'opportunité de voir partagée
qui m'a ouvert la porte sur le monde
entier sainthia découvre une douzaine de
groupes facebook destinée aux victimes
d'être elysées bandelettes
j'ai vu que j'étais passeurs qui avait
des milliers des milliers de personnes
comme moi qui avait les mêmes même
symptôme le plus commun c'est la douleur
dans les jambes
la région du vagin la région pelvienne
dans notre groupe
cette femme sur dix n'ont plus de vie
sexuelle à cause de leurs bandelettes
fait mach lane continent après avoir
elle-même souffert de la pose d'une
bandelette la britannique 400 âmes sonne
est devenue l'une des porte étendards
mondiale du mouvement anti bandelettes
saint-brice quelqu'un doit admettre
l'ampleur du désastre
et arrêtez de dire que ça ne touche
qu'une minorité le groupe facebook créé
par 400 hommes sling de mèche en
français balancela bandelettes à mener
une campagne efficace en 2017
l'utilisation des très vive à gino a été
restreinte au royaume uni et
l'utilisation des bandelettes vient
d'être suspendu elles sont faites du
même plastique pas rester les maîtres de
la même façon dans les nerfs et les
tissus
c'est le même problème et les
complications des bandelettes sont moins
graves et moins fréquentes que celles
des tra i vaginaux mais il est exact
qu'elles sont de même nature
il ya beaucoup de raisons pour laquelle
peuvent faire mal la raison disons la
plus fréquente semblerait qu'il ait trop
de tension sur la bandelette ce qui va
écraser un petit peu les nerfs autour de
l'urètre
le docteur jacques corcos est un
neurologue réputée de l'hôpital général
juif
malgré les complications potentielles
contrairement à 400 seul il n'a pas peur
des bandelettes
c'est le le gold standard pour les pour
le changement continence urinaire
on en voit très peu on voit très peu de
complications je me souviens pas
personnellement
de plus que deux patientes en 25 ans à
qui j'aurais des bandelettes que j'ai
posé mon le docteur corcas et
probablement un virtuose en matière de
chirurgie deux vastes études publiées
récemment au royaume uni révèle un taux
de ré opérations de 5% et un taux de
complications de 10% dans les cinq
années suivant l'implantation d'une
bandelette au canada ça veut dire des
milliers de femmes qui expérimente des
problèmes des problèmes donc bien
souvent selon notre enquête on ne les
avait pas prévenus on a un peu jeté
vraiment choqué
cynthia découvert que l'on et demi avant
sa chirurgie santé canada a publié un
avis demandant aux médecins
davies et leurs patientes des
complications potentielles liées aux
bandelettes
est-ce qu'on va parler des risques
sociales n'ont aucune mention de
complications possibles
les complications ne sont pourtant pas
banal perforation de l'urètre ou du
vagin par la bandelette douleurs aiguës
ou chroniques problèmes urinaires
relations sexuelles douloureuses dont le
dossier de cynthia son neurologue a
inscrit risques et complications
expliqué mais cynthia maintien qu'on lui
a mentionné les complications inhérentes
à toute chirurgie mais pas celles qui
sont liées à l'utilisation des
bandelettes leur est vraiment évaluer en
fait je l'aurais pas fait nous avons
parlé à six femmes opérées par là-même
urologue que cynthia toutes ont affirmé
ne pas avoir été informés des
complications mentionné dans l'avis de
santé canada vous avez eu comme une
réponse peut-être un centaine de femmes
qui vont répondre vous conseille ouais
cynthia a fondé le premier groupe de
support québécois destiné aux porteuses
de bandelettes en une semaine 80 femmes
se sont manifestés
on s'est rendus quand on est plusieurs à
avoir les mêmes problèmes et les femmes
ça expliquerait pourquoi j'étais mal aux
anges expliquerait pourquoi j'ai tant
mal leur haleine des femmes étaient
surprises ont fait pas toujours le lien
et car on va voir nos médecins ne nous
informe pas toujours en fait je suis
même pas certain qu'ils le savent qu'ils
ont un lien et marseille ils vont dire
c'est de l'arthrite
c'est un problème de disque un problème
de vésicules de l'endométriose des
fibromes on est face à un déni
institutionnels pire à une trahison
institutionnels joyau cynthia décide de
trouver un médecin qui va la débarrasser
de sa bandelette la démarche sera
pénible en est moins choquant non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en quelques semaines cynthia va consulté
plusieurs médecins spécialistes
premier rendez-vous docteur nathalie
leroux hureaux gynécologue à l'hôpital
sainte justine
elle m'a fermé capteurs pour m'enlever
ça demande est là que c'était une
opération est reversé des qu'ici pensais
pas que je pourrais trouver quelqu'un
qui ont beso complètement la spécialiste
suggère de faire une scintigraphie
osseuse pour s'assurer qu'il n'ya pas
d'infection ou d'inflammation et de
procéder ensuite à des injections de
cortisone pour soulager les douleurs
deuxième rendez vous l'urologue jacques
corcos de l'hôpital général juif une
proposera lever partiellement en fait la
partie vaginale
nous aurons son trousseau tu sors mon
but lotois confondre fidèles au sport et
aux croisés lourds pour ça suffit
troisième rendez vous une autre urologue
réputé dr lee mais tu du centre
hospitalier universitaire de sherbrooke
docteur sim propose de retirer ma banque
gleb complet
[Musique]
cynthia se retrouve avec quatre
propositions de traitement pour un même
problème des injections de cortisone
avec docteur leroux un retrait partiel
de quelques centimètres avec docteur
morissette qui a posé la bandelette un
retrait partiel substantielle avec
docteur corcos et un retrait total avec
dr tu avais mais je sais plus à qui
faire confiance
cynthia communique via sky avec le
docteur dionisio ce véronique is un
héros jean écologue américain qui dit
avoir retiré des milliers de treillis
des bandelettes
il m'assure que je dois absolument
élever la bande est au complet et nos
pôles en lever partiellement lui me dit
qu stenay c'est extrêmement
une opération extrêmement difficile
enfin cynthia une bandelette de type tv
théo fabriqué par une filiale de la
compagnie johnson & johnson
elle passe sous l'urètre et ressort à
l'intérieur des cuisses
après avoir traversé une zone délicate
du bassac d'approcher cette zone
nécessite de couper des muscles de deux
côtés les muscles sont pas mal
utilisabilité du bassin à la mobilité de
la jaune l'autre type de bandelettes
qu'on appelle tvt est plus facile à
retirer dans le tvt le la bandelette
ballet se mettre en arrière de l'os
pubien donc par une ouverture de
l'abdomen on peut très facilement aller
d'ici que cette cette zone et enlever
complètement la bandelette les deux
bandelettes s'équivalent alors pourquoi
continue-t-on d'installer des tv théo si
leur retrait comporte plus de risque
pour les patientes
c'est une bonne question aussi le tvt
eaux représentée à l' avantage par
rapport au tvt de présenter peut-être
moins de complications surtout pour des
gens qui ont pas vraiment l'habitude de
le faire
en d'autres mots les tvt au sens plus
facile à installer pour les médecins
l'autre avantage qu'il a ce qu il est
plus rapide parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
de faire de ciste copie pour vérifier si
on nombreux récits ou pas donc les gens
préfèrent aller toujours plus vite et
ont adopté cette technique
jamais j'aurais dû faire ça sainthia
hésite entre retrait partiel assez
simple et un retrait total qui
représente une chirurgie majeure
ça me fait vivre beaucoup d'insécurité
je fais connaître de l'angoissé angoisse
on peut savoir ce qu'est ce que est ce
que je vais prendre la bonne décision si
elle opte pour un retrait complet
cynthia devra aussi choisir entre une
chirurgienne québécoise qui en a fait
quelques-uns et un chirurgien américain
qui dit en avoir fait des centaines mais
dont les services sont loin d'être
gratuit
le montant aux seuls cas je reposte un
gros manteau comme et ça peut vous
coûter dalle aux états unis et environ
25000 dollars le minimum
cynthia décide de se rendre à saint
louis au missouri pour rencontrer le
docteur dionisio ce vernis qui sont le
symbole de la ville
une arche d'une hauteur de 200 m évoque
tout de suite pour nous une gigantesque
bandelettes nous retrouvons cynthia à
l'aéroport ça fait bon voyage
mais c'est une liste des questions aussi
longtemps et beaucoup combiné question
12 points votre but en sortant de ce
rendez vous là c'est quoi
mon but c'est de repartir rassurer puyet
sur un total tout chercher l'information
prêtes certain que fait le bon choix
on vient du monde entier pour se faire
opérer par docteur véronique hills après
avoir brièvement discuté avec cynthia il
nous fait sortir pour l'examiner
c'est ici qu'est votre bandelettes
ok ça c'est votre bandelettes
ok pour la première fois quelqu'un
explique à cynthia exactement d'où
viennent ces douleurs il faut toucher la
bandelette quand je les fais vous avez
vraiment très mal n'ai fait qu'un
docteur véronique is explique qu'avec le
temps la bandelette s'enchevêtrent dans
les tissus dans les n est l'alliée deux
groupes de muscles qui sont faits pour
fonctionner indépendamment les muscles
sont spasmes et et irrité la bandelette
s'est tendu et presse sur la paroi
vaginale un retrait partiel selon lui ne
réglerait pas le problème
au début de ma pratique je faisais des
retraits partiels sur des tv théo mais
les femmes ont continué d'avoir
certaines douleurs dans les airs à
montréal le docteur jacques corcos
préfère procéder par étapes dont la très
grande majorité des cars l'ablation par
c'est de la mauvaise est suffisante si
ça ne suffisait pas en ce moment là on
pourra envisager d'aller chercher le
reste du monde mauvaise idée selon
docteur véronique est ce une ablation de
la partie vaginale rendrait plus
difficile et risqué lors d'une deuxième
opération d'enlever des portions qui
sont restés dans les haines
font c'est faux on pose des bandelettes
depuis plus de 20 ans et la communauté
médicale ne s'entendent toujours pas sur
ce qu'il faut faire en cas problème
la vérité c'est qu'on n'a pas la
solution il n'y a pas de registre qui
documentent que vivent les patientes
personne n'a vraiment réfléchi au
problème
personne n'a la solution la militante
cats and sun demande que les bandelettes
soit utilisée en dernier recours
seulement elle souhaite qu'on offre
d'abord aux patientes des chirurgie
traditionnelle plus invasive mais qui
ont fait leurs preuves
elle admet que la transition pourrait
être difficile mèche
les bandelettes ont été vendus depuis 20
ans comme une solution miracle
économique et rapide
beaucoup de cire urgent ne savent plus
faire les chirurgie traditionnelle tout
ce qu'ils connaissent ce sont les
bandelettes
un recours collectif contre le fabricant
de bandelettes boston scientific vient
d'être autorisée au canada et des
recours contre deux autres fabricants
don johnson & johnson sont en attente
d'autorisation
johnson & johnson nous a offert le
commentaire suivant les bandelettes
améliore la qualité de vie de la
majorité des femmes le tvt et le
traitement pour l'incontinence à
l'effort qui a fait l'objet du plus
grand nombre d'études
sachant que toute chirurgie comporte des
risques une discussion entre médecins et
patiente pour soupeser les risques
versus les bénéfices est d'une
importance critique
l'urologue julie morissette qui a posé
la bandelette de cynthia n'a pas
retourné nos appels
[Musique]
j'ai décidé de larguer totalement par le
dr véronique est ce parce que c'est un
des meilleurs chirurgiens mans avec
d'expérience
nous avons revu cynthia deux semaines
après sa visite au missouri
par contre je pense que j'ai pas à payer
25 mille dollars pour réparer un
problème qui m'étais créé par le système
de santé c'est pour ça que j'ai envie de
m'adresser à aram cul pour qu'ils
puissent me rembourser une partie de
cette opération là où la totalité y
parce que je pense que j'ai pas à payer
pour retrouver l'air la personne que
j'étais à 20
un mot en conclusion de ce reportage
pour vous dire qu en ontario le
gouvernement à rembourser les frais
d'une vingtaine de femmes qui se sont
fait enlever treillis ou bandelettes à
l'extérieur du pays
[Musique]